لم يقدم الرئيس الفرنسي أي
اعتذارات عن حظر أنواع معينة من
الزي الإسلامي خلال العام الدراسي المقبل، حيث
يستهدف الحظر الأخير للفصول الدراسية
التحيز، وهو رداء طويل مثل الملابس على الرغم من
الانتقادات الحادة لهذا القرار،
وأكد الرئيس ماكرون يوم الجمعة مجددًا
أن التحيز والرموز الدينية الأخرى
لن تكون كذلك.  وقال إنه سيتم السماح للمعلمين بالدخول إلى المدارس الفرنسية،
وسيحصلون على
مساعدة إضافية لتطبيق هذه القواعد،
وفي أصعب المدارس الثانوية
سيتم انتداب موظفين خاصين للعمل
جنبًا إلى جنب مع مديري المدارس والمعلمين
لدعمهم والمشاركة في
الحوار الضروري مع العائلات
والتلاميذ.  لن نسمح لأي شيء أن
يفلت منا في بداية العام الدراسي الجديد
سأكون صريحًا معكم فنحن
نعلم أنه ستكون هناك حالات لأننا
نعلم أنه سيكون هناك البعض من خلال
الإهمال ربما ولكن الكثير منها نحاول
تحديها  أدان النظام الجمهوري، الذي يجب أن نكون
منتقدين لا هوادة فيه، الحظر الأخير باعتباره
حملة معادية للإسلام، لكن السيد ماكرون
قال إن عرض الرموز الدينية في
المدارس يتعارض مع سياسات التعليم العلمانية في فرنسا.